hey guys welcome to the behind the
scenes of wizard barf the movie
you know when they spent all that time
at nasa researching fluid simulations
and dynamics
it was all so that we could do
potion puke coming out of wizard's
mouths
so in coming up with this idea we play a
lot of dungeons and dragons and when we
play dungeons and dragons we like to
make up
crazy potions we're thinking hey what
would happen if we made a video about
wizards who had too many potions they
puke a lot and just be vomit all over
the place yeah so we decided to define
that for the internet so in order to do
the vomit simulations we use a program
called realflow realflow is basically
known for doing really good fluid
simulations they use it all the time in
commercials it's first we film our shot
with us pretending puke without anything
there so it kind of looked like
goofballs just in an alleyway dressing
up like wizards in the middle of like
this alley in los angeles and every once
in a while people would stumble into the
alley and like peek in and there'd be
like one wizard with a beard and all
this messed up face filming this other
wizard with a beard with another messed
up face and we just like turn to them
with their hoods but they just see two
wizards filming each other like coughing
in an alley yeah just pretending to
throw up probably was the most bizarre
scene for most people that day
one of the things you can do to like
take your effects to the next level is
do 3d camera tracking yeah we've talked
about it a lot before and we're planning
still
to do a tutorial about it yeah sorry
i've done the chance basically we use a
motion tracking program there's a lot of
different kinds out there to track the
position of the camera then we rebuilt
some of the geometry of the scene so
that the puke could interact with it for
example you'll see it bouncing off the
walls and hitting the ground and all
that kind of stuff so we need to get the
bark to come out of our mouths once
again in this case it was easiest for us
to just animate it by hand so you want
to come up with like a system that makes
it quick and easy so the first thing i
did is i would just take an object in
this case cylinder and just kind of
track it to the position of the person
roughly like every five frames move it
to the new spot then i put a little tiny
pyramid
where my mouth was pointing in the
direction where the barf would come out
i would parent the pyramid to the to the
cylinder or whatever object was
representing the person so as the person
moved this little like emitter would
roughly be in the same spot then all i
had to do was go around and make little
tweaks to actually kind of keep it on
the map so anyways after doing this for
every shot
we could then take this into the
program for fluid simulations called
realflow so once we built the scene and
animated where the guys have to barf in
realflow uh there's two stages to making
your liquid the first is basically
having a particle pass where you spew
out all these little particles that have
the properties of water such as like
surface tension viscosity you know they
glob together and they're running and
stuff like that
but they're not actually liquid yet
once you have that first particle
simulation done you actually make a mesh
out of it which is the program looks at
all the dots and where they are and
makes an averaged out 3d model that
coats and surrounds all the particles
giving it that actual solid liquid form
and once we have that we basically bring
that right back into 3ds max and it is
just a model an animated moving
displacing model so anyways we bring
this back into 3ds max and you have
geometry that now represents the liquid
but now you got to make the liquid look
like liquid so we do all our rendering
in a renderer called mental ray it comes
with 3ds max
and it's really really good at doing
accurate light simulation and really
good materials and surface properties on
set for the stuff we were drinking it's
all just like gatorade and powerade with
maybe a little extra food coloring to
make it a little more vibrant so that's
kind of like what we tried to replicate
so in 3ds max i made a material that was
the correct amount of shininess correct
amount of transparency had a little bit
of translucency a little bit that milky
kind of like quality that the potions
had that we were drinking as long as
you've set up your lights correctly in
the scene once you build all that
things actually end up looking pretty
realistic when you put it all together
so you just render out passes you render
out your puke pass without any shadows
then you write out shadow paths bring
that into after effects everything is
motion tracked so you just simply drop
it in drop in your shadows do a little
bit tweaking of the levels always tweak
the levels
and then you have your final shot yo
extra special pro tip real smart motion
blur it calculates motion blur
on anything so rather than having to
deal with trying to figure out how to
render out motion blur for this you just
apply real smart motion blur now for the
fire we used something called fume
effects which is a plug-in for 3ds max
it specializes in creating smoke and
fire now as you can see here i had to go
through a lot of iterations to get what
i wanted and it looks really really bad
but that's because i'm simulating in low
resolution with low quality because it
goes much much faster and i can hone in
on the motion and movement that i want
once i have that i then simulate a high
resolution version which takes much
longer but the flames look much more
detailed i take this into after effects
play with the colors to make them more
match the scene add some embers some
glow and some motion blur to make it all
look more realistic and tie it together
and then i have my final composition
so this is the outro where we say that
we hope you guys learned something from
this video we also tend to mention our
twitter
um facebook
gesture on the screen because you know
we also have to mention our facebook i
just did you mention that i just
mentioned it
okay well here's the video links
zoom out
that's okay it'll be really
you